merci d'être avec nous Christine Laval
vous êtes élus des hautes membres du
groupe les républicains vice-présidents
de la commission des finances et on a
beaucoup de sujets budgets à voir avec
vous puisque cet après-midi le Sénat
entame l'examen du budget 2023 l'année
dernière vous aviez coupé court au débat
budgétaire cette année vous irez
jusqu'au bout mais cette année on sera
même la seule chambre en fait à étudier
le budget dans sa globalité aussi bien
les recettes et les dépenses donc c'est
un long travail de 15 jours qui s'ouvre
devant nous ça change les choses le fait
que ce budget était adopté via 49-3 à
l'Assemblée nationale ça change quelque
chose au moment où vous entamez l'examen
de ce mais on voit bien qu'il y a un
certain nombre de thèmes et de missions
qui n'ont pas fait l'objet d'un débat
entre les différentes sensibilités
politiques et ce débat il aura lieu au
Sénat sur tous les points de l'action
publique c'est un budget sur lequel un
compromis pardon est possible avec le
gouvernement alors je sais pas c'est un
compromis est possible sur ce budget en
tout cas ce qui est certain c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un ensemble un peu
un collectif budgétaire qui reste en
suspens il vous a pas échappé qu'on a
une loi de programmation des finances
publiques qui a été rejetée à
l'Assemblée nationale votée par le Sénat
avec une trajectoire modifiée qui nous
semble plus responsable plus responsable
parce qu'elle demande à l'état de venir
faire un effort alors que l'État demande
au collectivités de le faire mais ne
s'imposer rien à lui-même un budget
aussi enfin nous avait avancé l'objectif
de réduction du déficit de réduction du
déficit on a demandé à l'état de faire
des économies pour engager des réformes
structurelles parce que aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui manque vraiment et on va
encore le voir dans ce projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 en fait il n'y a pas
de réforme structurelle on continue à
déverser de l'argent par les fenêtres
pour maintenir le pouvoir d'achat des
Français mais sans s'intéresser sur
l'efficacité des politiques publiques
qui sont derrière et pourquoi comme
réforme structurelle quelle est la
réforme structurelle prioritaire si on a
une mais par exemple tout à l'heure
j'entendais la première ministre la
tribune de l'Assemblée nationale hier
dire nous voulons baisser notre
consommation d'énergie de 40% d'ici 2050
c'est énorme 40%. mais quand elle dit ça
aujourd'hui il faut regarder où sont les
consommations d'énergie si c'est baisser
la consommation d'énergie en arrêtant
toute notre industrie mais est-ce que
c'est vraiment ça qu'on veut ce que
j'entends dans le même temps qu'on a
désormais un ministre de la souveraineté
industrielle et économique donc c'est
pas possible aujourd'hui la consommation
d'énergie c'est en gros pour un tiers
les transports et pour un tiers le
logement
les transports on va arrêter de se
déplacer on va peut-être se déplacer
différemment on va peut-être se déplacer
mieux mais par exemple si on arrête le
transport par voiture pour passer par du
transport ferroviaire ça nécessite plus
de consommation d'électricité donc il
faut bien qu'on la produit cette
électricité il faut qu'on la produise de
manière décarbonée donc ça veut pas dire
qu'on va moins consommer d'énergie on va
consommer de l'énergie plus propre le
deuxième gros paquet c'est le logement
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour le
logement enfin quand j'entends le
président de la République dimanche qui
se gargarise sur une vidéo TikTok ou
snapchat enfin que ça en tout cas un
média un peu décalé pour un président de
grand public si je peux me permettre
dire qu'on fait énormément il compte
quoi il compte des dossiers où on a
distribué une prime la prime ma prime
rénove quand on distribue une prime pour
changer son mode de chauffage
objectivement on ne fait rien pour
diminuer la consommation d'énergie du
bâtiment on lui permet juste de
consommer moins cher ce qu'il faut faire
c'est de la rénovation globale s'il faut
engager un vrai plan Marshall dans les
copropriétés chez les bailleurs sociaux
ça nécessite beaucoup de fonds publics
ça nécessite de créer une véritable
filière avec des professionnels
certifiés qui disposent des compétences
et dont on est sûr qu'ils vont vraiment
faire de la rénovation globale et qui
vont pas vendre que un peu comme ce
qu'on a connu pour le photovoltaïque au
début de son essor et ça c'est de la
police c'est des vrais enjeux de
politique publique c'est des réformes
structurelles et aujourd'hui elles ne
sont pas par exemple ce budget de
l'écologie il va être très discuté pour
vous il n'est pas à la hauteur il ne
répond pas aux enjeux ah bah pour moi ce
budget de l'écologie on a de l'argent ça
on peut pas dire le contraire mais de
toute façon c'est un peu comme partout
on rajoute de l'argent en faisant croire
qu'avec ça on va s'en sortir mais mais
non enfin on rajoute de l'argent sur
l'éducation nationale pour venir
augmenter la rémunération des
enseignants ce qui est un sujet et le
rapport Gérard Longuet l'avait montré
mais derrière on ne se pose aucune
question sur la manière d'enseigner sur
est-ce que c'est efficace et ce qu'on va
venir diminuer le décrochage scolaire
quand je vois que là on met une rustine
sur les mathématiques en disant bah
allez on va en mettre une heure et demie
mais est-ce qu'on a vraiment répondu aux
enjeux de former des élèves qui ensuite
seront en capacité de mener des études
supérieures et de pouvoir poursuivre une
filière industrielle de recherche en
France j'en suis pas certaine il y a un
autre sujet qui risque de faire des
bases c'est la question des supers
profits alors ça fait des bas au sein
même de la majorité sénatorielle puisque
les centres ils sont favorables vous
vous y opposerez alors nous on s'y est
toujours opposés parce qu'on pense que
taxer pour taxer n'est pas forcément une
solution depuis le mois de juillet il y
a aussi des avancées qui ont été qui ont
été faites notamment parce que désormais
il existe un dispositif européen qui a
vocation à se traduire dans chacune des
législations nationales et c'est ce je
fais dans ce PLF qui vient en fait taxer
la rente inframarger rénale donc on va
dire les ressources exceptionnelles et
notamment des producteurs d'énergie
alors ce dispositif il y a encore
quelques failles des choses à améliorer
et il en sera certainement discussions
au Sénat après de savoir est-ce qu'il
faut venir tout taxer il y a
effectivement ceux qui profitent d'une
situation de manière exceptionnelle et
puis il y a ceux en fait qui derrière
produisent un service économique et qui
en fait vivent aussi avec le cycle de
l'économie et quand le on est en cycle
bas alors activité et elle aussi au
point bas on va continuer à parler
budget on va parler pouvoir d'achat
budget des collectivités à travers le
vote du budget rectificatif c'était hier
hier soir au Sénat vous l'avez voté mais
quelque peu modifié on va tout ça avec
Audrey vital
[Musique]
qui ne va pas tarder à arriver voilà qui
arrive à les yeux Audrey on dirait
bonjour bonjour et hier Audrey les
sénateurs ont adopté le second projet de
loi de finance rectificative de l'année
51 200 pardon 51 voix pour 28 contre
avec entre autres 2,5 milliards d'euros
d'être face à l'inflation oui
d'ordinaire ce texte a pour but
d'ajuster simplement les dépenses par
rapport au budget adopté un an plus tôt
mais cette année la crise des énergies
et l'inflation sont passées par là alors
le gouvernement a mis en place des
mesures d'urgence qui ont été acceptées
par l'Assemblée nationale sans passer
par le 49,3 hier le ministre s'en est
réjouit adopté donc par le Sénat à
majorité de droite parmi ces mesures il
y a le chèque énergie exceptionnel de
100 ou 200 euros qui concernera tout de
même 12 millions de foyers un fond de
275 millions d'euros pour aider les
universités à faire face à la hausse des
prix des énergies 200 millions d'euros
supplémentaires aussi pour l'armée pour
acheter du carburant en opération
extérieure et la fameuse remise
quand même ce nouveau chèque énergie
qu'il a est distribué de manière
beaucoup plus large que les premiers
chèques puisque en gros le chèque
énergie dans son assiette classique
c'est 5,8 millions de bénéficiaires là
on a une assiette beaucoup plus large à
12 millions on observe effectivement
qu'aujourd'hui l'énergie et un sujet et
encore des études récentes montrent que
les dépenses contraintes dans le ménage
des Francs dans le budget des ménages va
croissants en fait parce que notamment
le poste énergie pèse beaucoup avec
l'alimentation donc il y avait nécessité
à faire ça et ça quand on fait un chèque
énergie c'est ciblé ça vient directement
se défalquer des factures donc il y a
pas de perte en ligne en fait il y a pas
dévoiement on peut pas l'utiliser pour
autre chose donc là ça c'est un
dispositif efficace parce qu'il répond à
une vraie problématique c'est aider les
plus fragiles à venir faire face à des
dépenses qui sont contraintes et subies
après on pourrait discuter de tout un
tas d'autres sujets mais vous avez pas
dit que notamment dans ce PLF et ça a
été adopté à l'assemb nationale mais on
y apporte un regard très bienveillant il
y a des dispositifs qui ont été faits
aussi pour venir justement accélérer la
rénovation thermique dont on discutait
tout à l'heure en venant augmenter les
crédits dédiés à cette politique et ça
il y a vraiment besoin de le faire et
moi je pense qu'il y a vraiment besoin
de le faire aussi en venant mobileiser
l'argent du secteur privé que ce soit
les particuliers et les entreprises par
des diminutions de recettes d'accord on
se on s'enlève des choses pour le court
terme mais c'est vraiment des
investissements de long terme qui demain
permettront de justement de plus jeter
de l'argent par les fenêtres pour venir
couvrir des dépenses d'énergie trop
élevées effectivement il y a d'autres
choses qui ont été votées par les
sénateurs parce que les sénateurs ont
inventé le texte oui et des choses
notamment sur les collectivités vous
êtes beaucoup monté au créneau en faveur
des collectivités 60 millions d'euros de
plus pour la réflexion des ponts pour
aider notamment les petites communes 100
millions d'euros de crédit
supplémentaires pour renforcer
l'entretien des réseaux d'eau après un
été de sécheresse il faut savoir que les
fuites font perdre 20% du volume d'eau
dis chaque année à noter aussi qu'il y a
eu un moment un peu d'incompréhension
car un Nati un article du texte pardon
prévoit de créer 53 nouveaux postes
auprès des services de la première
ministre alors où on demande des efforts
budgétaires au collectivités notamment
c'est vrai qu'il y a eu beaucoup de
questions là-dessus l'État ne semble pas
prendre sa part ça a donné lieu à des
interrogations le sénateur canvett a
même déposé un amendement pour en
réduire le nombre écoutés chez PLFR se
traduit par un certain nombre de
créations de postes alors même sans
doute qu'on aurait pu attendre le PLF
pour avoir une vue d'ensemble beaucoup
plus large et donc il importe de
maîtriser mais il importe surtout madame
la Présidente que
l'exécutif au plus haut montre l'exemple
et c'est sur les services du Premier
ministre que un nombre important de
postes sont créés et il nous paraît
opportun que le cette maîtrise
intervienne et que donc l'augmentation
du nombre de postes ce soir
circonscrites au minimum absolu c'est à
dire à 20 au Sénat c'est un moyen aussi
pour je vais vous montrer que lorsque
l'état demande aux collectivités locales
de faire un effort et bien l'état montre
l'exemple donc je soutiendrai ces
amendements alors le ministre a expliqué
au sénateur que ces postes se réfléchi
sur le Secrétariat à la mer où celui de
l'économie sociale et solidaire il
semble que ça a convaincu votre collègue
Michel canevett puisqu'il a retiré son
amendement écouter la réaction ça va
aller très vite
je suis sensible aux propos du ministre
je retire mon amendement
donc on l'a entendu qu'il soit voté
parce qu'il aurait reçu notre
assentiment et effectivement aujourd'hui
par exemple on crée un secrétariat
général à la transition écologique mais
objectivement aujourd'hui on a déjà un
ministère de la transition écologique
est-ce qu'on avait vraiment besoin de
créer ce secrétaire général qui de toute
façon va par la force des choses
fonctionner avec des moyens qui existent
déjà dans ce dans ce ministère mais par
contre on rajoute quand même des postes
donc à force de sur administrer de créer
des comités droites à gauche on en
oublie même qu'on a déjà les compétences
en interne dans l'état et là vous citez
à un certain nombre par exemple les 100
millions qui sont dédiés aux agences de
l'eau pour les travaux d'assainissement
enfin je veux juste ici peut-être dire
que là c'est 100 millions de véritables
argent pour venir faire de la politique
publique ce ne sont pas les 100 millions
qui ont été annoncés par la première
ministre en déplacement à Marseille ou à
la uniquement en fait autorisé les
agences de l'eau après lever sur leur
donc c'est quand même quelque chose de
très différent
je sais pas on le dit comme on veut mais
là c'est vraiment 100 millions parce que
effectivement et vous avez très
justement rappelé un moment où on nous
demande de faire des dépenses d'économie
de sobriété c'est quand même
inimaginable de penser qu'on perd de
l'eau par nos réseaux qui sont
défaillants parce qu'il y a des mesures
en plus qui ont été votées avec des
crédits en plus est-ce que c'est
compatible avec la ligne que vous tenez
à savoir on augmente pas la dépense
publique il faut faire attention à nos
finances alors aujourd'hui sur ces deux
sujets là c'est des sujets qui sont un
peu oubliés ou par en pauvres parce que
notamment sur la réflexion des ports des
ponts pardon il y a eu d'importants
travaux du Sénat à la suite de drame qui
ont montré qu'aujourd'hui on avait des
infrastructures vieillissantes et
derrière le gouvernement l'exécutif n'a
pas agi pour venir entreprendre des
mesures donc c'est aussi là une manière
de leur envoyer un signal et de toute
façon en fait ce PLFR parce que ça c'est
très peu comparé
au milliard que le gouvernement lui-même
ajoute il est financé en fait par des
recettes dites exceptionnelles la
croissance en fait a été plus élevée que
ce qui était escompté et quand il y a de
la croissance on a des recettes fiscales
et sociales qui permettent de venir
financer ces dépenses mais ça vous a
peut-être pas mais on a eu quand même un
amendement un article d'équilibre à 60
millions enfin moi ça m'était jamais
arrivé d'avoir un article d'équilibre
aussi petit donc c'est bien pour montrer
qu'en fait la discussion elle a été
vraiment enfin tout à fait
responsable et qu'on voilà c'est aussi
là une manière de dire qu'il y a des
sujets sur lequel il faut agir et là
c'est des investissements dans la durée
un peu à contre-courant de ce qui est
fait ou vraiment là on fait du court
terme et j'ai pas dit qu'il fallait pas
protéger le pouvoir d'achat mais il faut
peut-être le protéger en réfléchissant à
ce qu'on fait c'est compatible vous
pensez que c'est entendre parler
français ce discours de de faire
attention à la dépense publique alors
que les Français ont du mal à boucler
leur fin de mois et que ils demandent
des aides de la part du gouvernement et
je vais vous dire un autre exemple alors
c'est un peu toujours autour de
l'écologie mais c'est un sujet que je
connais pas mal aujourd'hui on dépense
plus d'un milliard pour un dispositif de
bonus et de prime à la conversion pour
dire au ménage abandonnez votre véhicule
thermique prenez un véhicule électrique
oui il s'avère que le dispositif est
très encadré déjà le véhicule ne peut
pas excéder un certain prix et donc il
s'avère que les véhicules qui ont été à
80% aider l'année dernière ce sont des
véhicules qui viennent qui sont produits
hors des frontières de l'Union
européenne est-ce que vous trouvez
normal que l'argent du contribuable à y
soutenir une filière industrielle qui
n'est pas européenne enfin je suis
désolé mais pour moi c'est complètement
à contre-courant de l'idée de se
réindustrialiser de recréer des emplois
sur sur nos territoires donc ça je suis
désolé pour moi c'est de l'argent qui
est jeté par les fenêtres à mauvais
escient attend donc notre filière
industrielle soit prête les
constructeurs se sont en lancer dans la
transformation de leurs usines les
chaînes de production seront en capacité
de sortir des véhicules fin 2023 fois
2024 donc attendons et c'est d'ailleurs
des messages que nous on enverra au
gouvernement pendant la discussion du
budget et justement parce qu' hier soir
ça c'est plutôt bien passé il y a un
lien sujet budgétaire qui va être
examiné évidemment en budget c'est les
ce sont les collectivités territoriales
et les finances des collectivités
territoriales il y a quelques jours vous
avez Alté le gouvernement sur sa volonté
d'encadrer les dépenses de ces
collectivités alors les députés avaient
voté dans votre sens ça a été remis par
49-3 est-ce que ça pour vous c'est une
ligne rouge vous êtes contre
l'encadrement des dépenses écoles on est
contre c'est vraiment une ligne rouge
c'était d'ailleurs l'objet ma question
au gouvernement la semaine dernière
parce qu'en plus la forme franchement
n'est pas là enfin je veux dire c'est
vraiment se moquer du Parlement que de
venir réintroduire dans un autre texte
dont on sait qu'il sera adopté par le
49-3 une disposition qui a été rejetée
par tout le monde enfin il y a que les
députés de la majorité et je sais même
pas si tous les sénateurs de la majorité
même pas puisque les sénateurs par
exemple du groupe horizon ont eux-mêmes
demandé la suppression de cet article
dans la loi de programmation leurs
études du texte en commission donc là
c'est encadrement des dépenses il y a
pas de vote du budget pour vous si
encadrement des dépenses de toute façon
il n'y aura pas d'accord possible sur
aucun des textes que ce soit la loi de
programmation ou le budget alors le
budget et ça regroupe beaucoup plus de
choses que uniquement cet aspect
encadrement des dépenses mais pour nous
aujourd'hui les collectivités elles sont
responsables enfin si les collectivités
elles arrivent à s'en sortir c'est déjà
tout simplement parce qu'elle doivent
présenter un budget équilibré ce que
l'État n'a pas comme contrainte donc
l'état qui n'a aucune contrainte lui ne
se met aucun garde-fou les collectivités
qui doivent présenter un budget en
équilibre qui leur seul levier c'est
d'aller lever l'impôt et le viol l'impôt
c'est quand même pas très populaire et
je rappelle que les élus locaux c'est
les profs ils sont apportés de baffe
comme on dit assez simplement donc elles
sont responsables et collectivités il y
a pas besoin de venir leur mettre
marteau en plumes le gouvernement vous
dit qu'il donne des moyens en
collectivité avec la dotation globale de
fonctionnement sera augmentée 320
millions d'euros c'est la première fois
depuis 13 ans qu'est-ce que vous dites
de ça alors c'est vrai mais c'est pas
vrai pour tout le monde parce que ce
qu'on ne dit pas c'est ce qu'on vient
augmenter on vient augmenter pas
l'enveloppe générale qui bénéficie à
toutes les collectivités sachant qu'un
certain nombre de collectivités
d'ailleurs ne bénéficient plus dotations
globale de fonctionnement donc elles
exercent des compétences au nom de
l'État gratuitement donc là on est
vraiment sur une efficacité de l'action
publique qui est infinie donc ça c'était
ma première remarque on est venu
augmenter la DSU on est venu augmenter
la DSR mais pour toutes celles qui n'ont
ni déesse une IDSR il y a pas grand
chose qui va se passer si ce n'est qu'en
fait elles n'auront pas de baisse
puisqu'on va maintenir la part centrale
du gâteau merci Audrey merci à tout à
l'heure on parlera d'un tout autre sujet
on va parler des trains oui totalement
des trains qui n'arrivent pas à l'heure
dans le club dans une demi-heure on va
aller voir l'actualité dans nos régions
on va Clermont-Ferrand on retrouve
Julien Bonnefoy bonjour Julien merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous Julien chargé
des opérations spéciales pour le groupe
Centre France évidemment ce sont les
journaux du centre de la France dont la
montagne Julien vous êtes justement
médiateur de la rédaction du journal La
Montagne vous expliquez aujourd'hui dans
vos pages que lors de la du monde au
kata il n'y aura pas que du foot dans le
journal
oui on aurait évidemment Ryan mais nous
avons fait le choix de marcher sur deux
jambes celle du sport et celle de la
politique et des droits de l'homme
évident notre service des sports a
travaillé main dans la main avec les
informations générales pour proposer de
2 à 4 pages tous les jours durant ce
Mondial ou à traiter des milliers de
morts sur les chantiers de l'argent roi
dans le football de l'hérésie écologique
constitue mondial au Qatar de la
corruption des droits de l'homme bafoué
on parlera aussi évidemment beaucoup de
foot de l'équipe de France de Didier
Deschamps de ses choix tactiques et
quand la France jouera en augmentera la
couverture forcément on ouvrira les
colonnes à des experts d'anciens joueurs
d'anciens coach illustre comme Guy Roux
par exemple qui sera notre chroniqueur
et on commence tous programme dès
aujourd'hui par un grand entretien avec
le géopolitologue Pascal Boniface et
puis samedi matin nous publierons un
dossier spécial sur le boycott
et justement Julien pourquoi ne pas
avoir fait le choix de boycotter ce
mondial dans vos colonnes
d'abord parce que nous avons un devoir
d'informer vous le savez cette Coupe du
Monde est un événement planétaire qui
sera regardé par des milliards de
téléspectateurs on doit le prendre en
compte en restant prudent on ne nous
contenons pas seulement au terrain de
foot car il y a aussi des questions
géopolitiques environnementales éthiques
que nous devons traiter tous ces
éléments nous oblige à regarder
l'événement avec de la distance et une
grande prudence pour proposer au lecteur
une offre d'information globale sur ce
Mondial au Qatar et puis l'autre raison
c'est justement le géopolitologue de
Boniface parce qu'elle Boniface qu'il
explique dans une interview ce matin
dans nos colonnes je le cite je préfère
la position d'Amnesty International qui
appelle plutôt à servir du Mondial pour
obtenir des améliorations de la
situation notamment concernant les
travailleurs immigrés boycotter ne
ferait pas avancer les choses selon lui
Christine Lavarde on sent une gêne dans
la classe politique vis-à-vis de cette
Coupe du Monde au Qatar peu de prise de
parole ni à gauche ni à la reine ni à
droite comment l'expliquer
alors c'est peut-être que déjà en tout
cas l'actualité pour nous elle est
chargée sur d'autres sujets
effectivement que la Coupe du monde de
football enfin voilà clairement au Sénat
on est focalisé plutôt sur les textes
budgétaires et je pense que voilà la
Coupe du monde va venir prendre le pas
surtout si l'équipe de France fait des
bons résultats au fur et à mesure des
journées et vous citiez un peu toutes
les conséquences de cette coupe du monde
et vous avez pas citer l'économie enfin
moi je suis toujours sidérée quand je
vois l'impact sur l'économie de ces
grands événements sportifs et on sait
bien que si notre équipe va loin on aura
un effet positif sur l'économie
française donc ça c'est peut-être la
chose réjouissante donc on va leur
souhaiter d'aller loin parce que ça sera
intéressant pour notre économie après
vous avez complètement raison sur tout
ce que vous disiez effectivement
aujourd'hui la Coupe du monde elle
organisée elle va avoir lieu c'est avant
tout quand même un événement sportif
donc est-ce qu'on doit priver les
joueurs est-ce qu'on doit priver ce ce
sport de son l'événement mondial qui
permet à chacun de se confronter et de
tester les niveaux j'ai envie de dire
non par contre est-ce qu'on aurait pas
dû avant se poser les bonnes questions
au moment où on a attribué la Coupe du
monde alors je vais pas revenir sur tous
les deux sous de cette affaire que je ne
maîtrise pas mais dont voilà il y a des
choses encore peut-être des pardon
d'ombres mais c'est à ce moment-là
vraiment qu'il aurait fallu se poser la
question donc quand Emmanuel Macron
parce que si l'équipe de France va loin
ce que ce que vous souhaitez ce qu'on
souhaite Emmanuel Macron ira au Qatar il
a dit qu'il irait les soutenir à partir
des demi-finales et cette nuit il a dit
je pense qu'il ne faut pas politiser le
sport ces questions là il faut se les
poser quand on attribue l'événement vous
êtes d'accord avec ça c'est ce que je
vous disais en fait effectivement après
quand lui ira au Qatar c'est là où
effectivement il pourra aussi avoir une
action
politique en venant dénoncer un certain
nombre de pratiques en dehors seulement
soutenir l'équipe de France il doit
aussi aller porter un message politique
s'il y va bah il doit effectivement
aller porter un message politique et
quand on voit qu'on organise une coupe
du monde dans un pays où il fait
extrêmement chaud d'ailleurs il y a qu'à
voir on a décalé calendrier
d'organisation de cet événement ce qui
n'est pas d'ailleurs sans impact après
sur les calendriers des championnats
nationaux et donc indirectement toujours
sur mes histoires de retour économiques
et autres avec des calendriers qui ont
été retirés enfin mais donc ça il devra
aller se positionner sur dire est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui est-ce que dans le monde
dans lequel nous vivons certains pays
plus aisés peuvent se permettre de
construire des stades climatisés et
qu'on ne sait qu'un stade climatisé ça
fonctionne avec des fluides qui ont un
impact sur l'environnement sur la couche
sur la couche d'ozone voilà ça c'est des
choses qu'il doit dire pour ce pour
éveiller en fait la fin le le chaque
citoyen en fait à des incohérences c'est
à dire que le supporter de foot il va se
réjouir de l'organisation de voir des
matchs après il faut qu'ils se il faut
qu'il arrive à percevoir les conditions
dans lesquelles c'est match se réalisent
et puis aussi besoin finalement de ce
message parce qu'après comment peut-on
demander à quelqu'un de ne pas utiliser
sa voiture au diesel pour aller
travailler quand il va voir que d'autres
actions ont un impact climatique
beaucoup plus élevé et ce qu'aujourd'hui
on doit continuer à construire à
outrance de nouvelles infrastructures
sportives alors je sais que quand le
bâtiment va tout va ok mais on utilise
des matériaux on utilise des ressources
on artificialise aujourd'hui par exemple
la politique qui a été choisie pour
l'organisation des Jeux olympiques de
Paris ou au maximum on essaie d'utiliser
des installations qui existent déjà me
semble quelque chose de beaucoup plus
vertueux et permettra aussi à
l'écosystème sport de perdurer plus
longtemps un dernier mot Julien
non j'ai écouté la réponse c'était pas
je vous posais une question sur la
chaîne en fait et finalement vous
l'exprimer aussi ce matin merci
Julien son édition de Clermont c'est
clairement en chantier c'est à la Une de
votre journal merci beaucoup Julien
Bonnefoy d'avoir été avec nous merci
Christine lavande et bon examen du
budget ça commence cet après-midi à 15h
ce sera suivant direct évidemment sur
notre antenne merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir été avec nous bonne journée à
vous dans 20 minutes dans le club des
territoires on parlera des terres des
galères des usagers des thé vert
notamment dans les Hauts-de-France votre
collègue Jérôme Bacher sera avec nous
pour nous raconter tout ça d'abord on a
que Christophe Béchu
[Musique]